donc timide
en français par penser on
k mais de quel cadre par le temps - et
j'ai toujours pensé que ça venait
ailleurs deux mois mois les cadres j'ai
toujours pensé qu'il m'était imposé
qu'il venait de l'extérieur des autres
ça commence avec les besoins primaires
le besoin de manger boire dormir puis
ensuite viennent la timidité la peur
d'enfreindre les règles mais aussi la
peur de décevoir la volonté d'agir de
manière éthique ça commence avec les
consignes parental puise avec les règles
des jeux de société la grammaire
viennent ensuite les lois le code de la
route les contrats de travail le contrat
de mariage
mais pourquoi je m'impose tout ça à la
base pour ta survie les sentiments et
les peurs sont là en nous pour nous
aider à vivre le plus longtemps possible
en nous incitant à prendre soin de nous
à nous nourrir à ne pas nous confronter
à un trop gros danger mais alors si j'ai
ces garde-fous
pourquoi la société m'impose ça à la
base pour notre survie pour que la
liberté des angles puisse commencer là
où s'arrête celle des autres les règles
d'une société existe pour qu'on puisse
cohabiter
théoriquement sans trop nous entretuer
finalement je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
tant de différences que ça entre nous
deux approches finalement qu'ils soient
extraits secs ou intrinsèque
les cadres ont le même objectif que
chaque individu puisse exister dans une
société donnée
bon ça c'est la théorie et parce qu'on
pratique c'est souvent infiniment plus
compliqué et ça marche pas toujours très
bien non on le constate tous les jours
malgré tout nos règles on a quasiment
réussi à détruire notre planète et dans
notre société il existe encore le
sexisme le racisme et toutes sortes de
discriminations envers les vieux les
malades les pour les handicapés et toute
personne qui s'éloigne à un tant soit
peu de la norme et le pire c'est qu'il
existe des cadres qui encourage ces
comportements nocifs mais alors pourquoi
parler de ces problèmes quand on est
florent pinceau est tombé sac est con et
vulgarisateur informatique sur youtube
qu'on est
ingénieur logiciel dans une société qui
s'appelle biotype pourquoi parler de ces
problèmes quand on est deux hommes
blancs issus de familles sans grosses
difficultés financières et cadres sup
dans un domaine d'avenir
bref pourquoi parler de ces problèmes
quand finalement on n'y est pas
confrontés
pourquoi parce que faisant partie de
cette tranche de population qui ne
subissant pas de discrimination graves
doit être aussi agir aux côtés de ceux
qui défendent leur coach chaque jour
c'est aussi à nous de créer un monde
dans lequel cela n'existe pas et au
moins dans un premier temps un monde
dans lequel on lutte contre ça en ne
faisant pas partie des dix criminels
c'est avec ces idées en tête qu'on a
travaillé pour créer un environnement
dans lequel on n'aurait pas tous ces
problèmes
un environnement dans lequel thinking
outside the box serait une solution
et ça a commencé plus ou moins
consciemment au cours de notre scolarité
je ne sais pas si quand vous étiez petit
vous aviez une idée bien précise de ce
que vous vouliez faire
en général ça commence avec pompiers
princesse ou vétérinaire et puis ça
évolue avec l'âge
- quand j'étais petit je m'en souviens
pas très bien et ce qui est clair c'est
qu'à partir de la cinquième je voulais
faire de l'informatique
le problème c'est que au début des
années 2000
l'enseignement de l'informatique était
quasiment inexistant du système scolaire
au collège j'ai compris que j'étais dans
un cadre et j'ai tout fait pour riom
sortir mais dévié des dévier des rails
du système scolaire n'est pas si évident
que ça alors j'ai dû passer par le lycée
assez mon bac pour enfin viser une école
qu'il lançait une l'informatique
l'université de technologie de troyes
qu'elle s'appelle à l'arrivée lui téter
c'était quelque chose ouais nombreux
sont ceux après le bac ceux qui partent
pour de nouvelles aventures
mais quitter le lycée c'est aussi et
avant tout quitter son cocon familial
quitter les gens qu'on a côtoyé pendant
environ dix huit ans c'est des gens qui
ne connaissent par coeur des gens qui
nous ont mis dans une boîte où ils
pensaient que nous étions à l'aise
et bien finalement on se retrouve
enfermé dans quelque chose qui ne nous
convient pas vraiment moi j'étais dans
une boîte qui était trop petite je
devais y être timide et réservé et
j'étais pas capables d'en sortir face à
ces gens là qui me connaissait et qui
attendaient ce comportement de man alors
quand j'ai su que j'étais accepté à lui
tu étais j'ai vu une opportunité pour
moi de sortir de cette boîte et de
m'exprimer autrement pour aller mieux
j'ai changé de cadre et c'était une très
bonne idée ça a bien marché aujourd'hui
tu fais un télex l'info rue de l'arrivée
à l'it était passé douche froide quand
j'ai compris la première année qu'il
faudrait attendre encore deux ans de
préparation intégrées avant de pouvoir
prendre un cours d'informatique ma
chance ça a été de croiser la route
d'une association lutte et enel groupe
l'association d'informatique des
étudiants de l'iut et et yes voilà enfin
une occasion d'accélérer les choses j'ai
pu viennent j'ai pu y est à prendre
l'administration des serveurs une
aubaine pour moi
à partir de ce moment j'ai compris que
j'avais la possibilité de faire des
choses dans ma vie qui avaient un réel
impact passe entre nous rien m'avait
empêché de rejoindre une association
d'informatique l'absence de l'idée
peut-être alors à la fin de ma première
année au bout de monter ces deux pour
parler aux 8es tiens j'ai tout fait pour
ne serait-ce qu'à voir un cours
d'informatique enseigner l'année d'après
un an plus tôt et ça a fonctionné dit
donc je n'étais plus tout à fait sûr les
rails c'est l'une de mes premières
expériences où j'ai compris que je
pouvais faire un peu bouger les lignes
et ce qui est assez marrant c'est que
moi au même moment j'ai commencé ce même
court sauf que moi j'étais plutôt plus
tard dans le cursus que ce qui était
prévu initialement
et ça c'est possible grâce au système de
lutte et et qui permet et encourage
thinking outside the box
au lieu d'avoir un parcours linéaire les
universités de technologie donne la
possibilité aux étudiants qui le
souhaitent et qui s'en donne les moyens
et bien de moduler leur cursus en
fonction de leur projet professionnel et
personnel pratiquer le tt ça nous a
aussi montré
qu'il était possible d'avoir un système
qui était complètement différent de ce
qui se faisait habituellement et que
pour autant ça marche très très bien
et finalement c'est dans ce court où on
était tous les deux un petit peu hors du
cadre qu'on s'est rencontré et qu'on a
commencé à travailler ensemble il ya 13
ans et notre collaboration a d'abord
pris la forme de travaux associatif au
sein du bureau des étudiants ou avec
l'organisation du gala
ça nous a permis de nous confronter au
monde professionnel avoir des clients
des fournisseurs des financeurs et
pétain tout comme des vrais adultes
mise à part que tout le monde continue à
vous considérer comme des gamins vous
pouvez vous pouvez avoir géré un projet
à la perfection avoir des arguments
infaillible avant gérer plus de 300000
euros de plus financier avoir organisé
un événement avec plus de 300000
personnes avec produire sur 1500
personnes
aucun problème peu importe puisque vous
êtes trop jeunes mal habillé sans emploi
et que vous le serez jugé que là dessus
entre nous aujourd'hui je trouve ça
assez anecdotique parce qu'encore une
fois c'est la seule c'est le seul
problème auquel nous étions confrontés
et dans l'absolu ce n'est rien du tout
en comparaison du fardeau de ceux qui
subissent le sexisme et le racisme
même avec du recul c'est complètement
symptomatique des discriminations issus
de préjugés ce qui est bien c'est que ça
nous a suffisamment marqué pour bannir
et vouloir bannir ce genre de
comportement des monde dans lequel on
évolue en parlant d' évolution
il arrive un moment où on termine sa
scolarité est donc là on est confronté
pour la première fois au monde du
salariat
pour ma part j'ai suivi la voie toute
tracée des sociétés de services en
informatique qui semblait être le chemin
incontournable pas pour démarrer à
travailler dans mon domaine c'est comme
ça que je me suis retrouvé en costume
dans une tour à la défense avec un bon
salaire
on promettait ça pour 40 ans au bas mot
une situation de rêve en tout cas c'est
ce que tout le monde s'accordait à dire
pour ma part ça a été plutôt une
désillusion puisque je venais d'un monde
hyper dynamique où tout était positif ou
presque et je me suis retrouvé dans une
routine métro ou trop longs boulot peu
intéressants d'autres cours tout ça pour
quelque chose qui m'intéressait pas
vraiment j'étais confronté à un nouveau
cadre à des nouvelles limites et ça ne
m'allait pas du tout donc gg
au bout d'un moment a essayé de me
conformer à ce qu'on attendait de moi et
a construit ma vie comme la société
l'attendait bah j'ai accepté que ça ne
m'allait pas et j'ai cherché un moyen de
faire autrement
à ce moment là je travaillais dans une
banque
il avait une plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'employés donc je me suis dit
que c'était relativement inconcevable de
voir changer ce système qui paraissait
quand même bien figé bien en place alors
pour réussir à atteindre mon objectif
j'ai appliqué une recette qui avait déjà
fonctionné par le passé j'ai changé
d'environnement pour ça j'ai accepté une
proposition de florent qui consistait à
monter une entreprise au travers de mes
différents stages en entreprise et grâce
au récit du salariat de mes amis plus
âgés
j'étais encore plus galvanisés par mon
envie de créer une entreprise vous
rendez compte
avoir la possibilité de s'abstraire des
règles dictées par les autres alors un
2010 je me suis lancé j'ai constaté j'ai
contacté deux de mes très bons amis dont
tom pour nous lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat c'est pour nous le
summum du cim king outside the pops donc
flou qu'il n'avait pas encore terminé
ses études nous propose est d'arrêter de
gagner de l'argent pour créer une
entreprise et ça alors qu'il n'avait pas
vraiment d'idée de en quoi consistait le
monde professionnel et alors qu'il
n'avait pas d'argent à apporter à la
faire bon bah moi dans cette situation
vous imaginez bien que j'ai dit oui bien
évidemment tout de suite
parce qu'en voyant le potentiel gains en
cadre de vie que je pouvais obtenir en
faisant ça je me suis que ça valait le
coup de sacrifier les économies que
j'avais fait jusque là et de quitter cet
emploi qui me convenait pas et ben on a
on a commencé mais à une condition
on a demandé à foix donc quand on
commence à travailler normalement
histoire de qui commence à se faire un
peu d'expérience quand même dans le
monde professionnel qui commence à se
constituer un réseau en dehors de celui
de l'école mais aussi tu gagnes de
l'argent bas pour pouvoir nous aider à
créer cette entreprise
mouais et c'était plutôt une bonne idée
en fait mon premier job a permis de
rejoindre une petite entreprise et j'ai
côtoyé des gens formidables et entre
nous ça ne m'a pas du tout éloigné de
mon objectif loin de là certains parmi
eux étaient eux mêmes entrepreneurs et
m'ont beaucoup soutenu lors de ma
création
et du coup en parallèle de nos emplois
on a commencé à se préparer donc on a
commencé à se mettre à mi temps va
ensuite on a on a eu nos premiers locaux
on a travaillé pendant deux ans pour se
préparer à cette création est le 18
avril 2002 on s'est lancé et on a créé
ikos technology enfin on avait
énormément de défis à relever
le premier d'entre eux c'était de rester
amis mais fallait aussi concret notre
environnement de travail
bacon créer une marque ont créé un
produit on recrute des gens et tout un
tas d'autres choses et à vrai dire la
création de notre entreprise a été un
franc succès nous avons mis en place
l'environnement dont nous rêvions au
maximum exempt des préjugés et des
suppositions toxiques on a créé un beau
produit nous communiquions beaucoup pour
atténuer nos tensions et nous avions un
process de recrutement aux petits
oignons
le tout en faisant évoluer ce qui ne
fonctionnait pas et en nous félicitant
nos succès d'organisation même créé une
belle structure ne garantit pas sa
pérennité
loin de là toutes nos efforts a été été
orientés vers la construction de notre
produit et 20 la constitution de notre
cadre de travail idéales
le truc c'est qu'une entreprise n'existe
pas pour faire naître un beau produit ou
pour être bien structuré dans le système
dans lequel on évolue
les entreprises sont faites pour créer
de l'argent ça on avait beau le savoir
on a quand même mis à peu près deux ans
à vraiment comprendre et réaliser ce que
ça impliquait et on s'est retrouvés du
coup dans une situation délicate
le compte en banque de notre entreprise
était quasiment vide et nos comptes en
tant que personnel
aussi on s'est du coup évidemment
demandé si on devait tout arrêter et
retourner à une vie plus conventionnelle
mais bon on s'est repris en main et on a
décidé de trouver une solution
on a d'abord cherché à lever des fonds
puis finalement on s'est associé à une
autre entreprise plus grosse d'une
vingtaine d'années qui cherchait à
s'ouvrir le marché sur lequel nous
travaillons sur le papier c'était
gagnant gagnant nous étions financés et
nous retrouvions à un bon salaire et
nous apportions notre technologie et
l'organisation que nous avions mis en
place avec succès génial ouais nous
apportions notre dynamisme et il combler
notre faiblesse commercial ou alors on
pratique ça c'est pas passé tout à fait
comme ça bon on a on a comment on les a
rejoints
et après avoir travaillé un moment avec
eux bon on s'est rendu compte qu'on
n'arrivait pas vraiment faire bouger les
cadres on était confronté à des
suppositions et à des préjugés permanent
qu'on n'arrivait pas à bouger
on n'a jamais vraiment réussi à intégrer
le groupe
en se rendant compte que finalement il y
avait pas vraiment de groupe parce que
chaque personne dans la société au vrai
plus pour elles mêmes que pour
l'entreprise
c'était une pâte qui était assez
difficile moralement
jusqu'au moment où on a réalisé est
acceptée en fait la situation était
bloquée
c'était sans doute comme ça depuis le
début après deux ans dans cette
situation
on a décidé de quitter l'entreprise en
à ce moment là on souhaitait souhaitait
partir ne souhaitait pas démissionner
parce qu'on estimait qu'on était sur la
bonne voie
là on a dû négocier avec eux pour
pouvoir faire une sortie propre et
pouvoir continuer ce qui était notre
quête dont l'environnement de travail
idéal en somme nous pensions nous
abstraire des cadres alors que nous
avions fait qu'on choisira un nouveau
celui de l'entrepreneuriat et voyons qu
on ne s'en sortait pas nous nous sommes
réfugiés au sein de plus de cadres
encore plus contraignants alors qu'est
ce qu'on peut retenir notre première
aventure entrepreneuriale et bien on en
a tiré deux grandes leçons
la première c'est que pour faire bouger
les choses il faut bien comprendre le
monde dans lequel on évolue et jouer
avec ses règles et la seconde c'est que
pour vivre dans un cadre qui nous
convient pas on a deux choix se résigner
et les accepter ou en sortir mise en
application avril 2010 cet art on quitte
la société
durant ces cinq années d'entrepreneuriat
on a appris énormément de choses
il ya un point qui ressortait en
particulier c'était notre volonté et
notre capacité à transmettre nos
connaissances
l'informatique est un domaine
indispensable aujourd'hui mais mal
compris c'est au moins aussi souvent une
source de frustration que quelque chose
qui nous est vraiment dans notre travail
au quotidien
en partant de ce constat est fidèle à
nos habitudes d'essayer des choses
nouvelles
on alors décidé de créer une chaîne de
vulgarisation sur internet s'appelle
qu'est-ce que tu geek et on a alors
découvert le monde des vidéastes
vulgarisateur de taille modeste et on
à creuser on a étudié ce monde pour s'y
faire une place
et cette fois gagner de l'argent donc on
a créé une entreprise sont vraiment
vouloir faire d'argent lapin se dit
qu'on pouvait faire une chaîne youtube
pour en gagner voilà
et oui on s'est vite rendu compte que ça
allait être compliqué c'était évident
mais on a cherché des solutions dès le
début cette fois oui et puis on est
arrivé très vite au constat que les
petits vulgarisateur avait du mal à
exister sur youtube que c'était un
système qui n'était pas vraiment fait
pour eux et surtout qu'il existait un
fossé entre un youtube qui permettait la
création de contenus de qualité mais qui
ne permettait pas une rémunération
suffisante pour le rendre pérenne et
quelque chose comme netflix qui à
l'opposé finances des contenus
professionnels à grands coups de
millions
le cas dont on avait besoin n'existait
pas donc on a décidé d'appliquer une
leçon qu'on avait apprise précédemment
il fallait en créer un nouveau
et juste à ce moment là on a croisé la
route de la société your type on a
décidé de leur présenter nos idées et il
s'avère qu'ils avaient dressé le même
tableau que nous et plutôt que de nous
laisser dans un coin créer un concurrent
nous on proposé aussitôt de nous
embaucher youtube c'est une équipe dans
laquelle on l'a retrouvé beaucoup des
choses qu'on avait mises en place pour
essayer de mettre en place
c'était des gens ouverts prêts à se
remettre en question et prêt à prendre
des risques pour nous accueillir
on a trouvé que c'était une très très
bonne idée d'accepter leur proposition
pour aller voir de l'intérieur ce qui
rendait tout ça possible
alors vous vous doutez bien qu'on a
appris notre temps cette fois pour y
étudier ce nouveau cadre chat échaudé
tout ça tout ça on n'y a trouvé des gens
formidables bienveillant à l'ecoute avec
l' envie de partager et de grandir
ensemble et qui contrairement à nous par
le passé n'ont pas oublié que la
rentabilité est clé pour la survie noz
de l'entreprise mais ce sans jamais
mettre l'humain et quels qu'ils soient
au second plan il semblerait donc qu'il
soit possible de trouver des cadres qui
nous conviennent sans avoir à les créer
toutes pièces oui
il semblerait qu'on se soit approché
très très près de notre environnement de
travail idéal ou et links and outside
the box est en fait le moteur pour
avancer notre quête de l'environnement
idéal n'est évidemment pas terminée on a
encore un peu de temps devant nous mais
on est plus confiant que jamais on est
sur la bonne voie et ce grâce à une
chose film king outside the box petukhou
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir de tout ce
qu'on vient de vous raconter
quelle que soit la position dans
laquelle on se trouve
nous serons dans des cadres le jeu va
donc être de trouver ce qui nous
conviennent si on n'y est pas bien
quelle qu'en soit la raison
on a un problème ce n'est pas normal ça
ne doit pas être normal changement de
position
ne laissons pas une situation qui ne
nous convient pas à s'installer la pire
chose qui puisse arriver c'est de
considérer que notre situation est
banale et la dernière chose s'est il
n'est jamais trop tard pour changer
oui il faut laisser de l'espace aux
autres faisons attention à nos
suppositions et des construisons nos
préjugés même solidement ancrées et
profondément inscrit en nous dans mon
exemple et laissons les gens s'exprimer
tant ou en dehors du cadre
le cadre professionnel c'est
principalement les relations avec nos
collègues le cadre personnel c'est
principalement les relations constitué
avec nos amis et hénin famille tous ces
gens c'est notre entourage au quotidien
cet entourage ça peut être notre moteur
comme notre frein pour être bien
il faut s'entourer de gens qu'ils le
sont également alors pensons à nous se
réjouit gaulliste prenant soin des
autres
merci à tous d'avoir écouté cette
conférence c'est est un affluent de
casques éthylique savalli
[Applaudissements]